I was starting from zero having you know
not that same partner that I had for 15
years like Oh writing and producing all
that normally what I would do in life is
run away from the past
Russians future and never live in
whatever was happening in the moment
after going through a public divorce
from her husband and collaborator Mutt
Lange and experiencing vocal issues
after contracting Lyme disease Shania
Twain is back with her first studio
album in 15 years now the record tells
Shania story of love life and betrayal
and includes life's about to get good
which debuted on The Today Show
[Music]
there's an ability to you know make you
feel good about a song that is full of
so much heartbreak yeah there's a lot of
conflicting emotions in this caliber
members and a lot of news about
diversity as well yeah but that's where
I'm at I'm in a place where you know
some days I feel bad about things and
other days I'm feeling quite good about
things and I'm just where I am in the
now with all of that is just owning
those feelings whether they're good or
bad okay oftentimes when we go through a
breakup you will see something in the
house that reminds you of that person
and you want it gone your back catalogue
is so tied to your ex do you feel very
differently about those songs now no or
they still mean the same thing they all
mean the same and that's part of being
where I am right now okay there was a
time when maybe yeah I felt like oh I
really don't know if I even want to do
that song anymore and it was awkward
I'm just feeling more comfortable with
all of that now I'm in a less awkward
place